[Music]  serena williams makes her pregnant debut  at the 2017 Met Gala the 35 year old  tennis pro put her growing bump on full  display during the Costume Institute  benefit at the Metropolitan Museum of  Art in NYC on Monday Serena stunned in a  form-fitting gorgeous emerald green  Versace gown with matching beating down  the front  she accessorized the look with emerald  diamond earrings  a diamond spike bracelet and of course  her huge engagement bauble while her  fiance and reddit co-founder Alexis  Ohanian rocked a sleek tux and bowtie  for the affair the two were all smiles  as they walked the carpet together  serena cradling her baby belly the  four-time Olympic gold medalist first  announced the pair were expecting with  this adorable swimsuit shot to snapchat  last month  you